الكريم لن يرد على وضع اوكرانيا بوتين
المطلوب الاول اطلالات وزيره خارجيه ليبيا
تثير جدلا في السوشيال ميديا شاب يستعيد
المشي بعد شلل دام لاكثر من 12 عاما هذه
الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
في تصريحات اغضبت موسكو اعلنت الاستخبارات
العسكريه في وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه عن
وضع الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين على راس
قائمه المطلوبين الكياف التي تخطط للتخلص
منهم في المقابل اوضح الناطق باسم الكريم
بان بوتين هو الهدف رقم واحد تعتبر
ارهابيه مشيرا الى ان العمليه العسكريه
الخاصه في اوكرانيا اكثر من مبرره واكثر
من ضروريه ويجب اكمالها بتحقيق الاهداف
المحدده بعد تلك التصريحات وذلك على حد
قوله
نشط واسع اثرتها الاطلالات الاخيره لوزيره
الخارجيه الليبيه نجلاء المنقوش واصبحت
حديث ما وقع التواصل الاجتماعي تقارير
افادت بان القصه بدات بجوله للمنقوش عربيا
واقليميا جولتها الاخيره اذا ارتدت خلالها
فساتين وازياء مختلفه اثارت موجه من
التعليقات المتباينه بين من انتقد غلاء
ثمنها واهتمام الوزيره بشكل الخارجي بقدر
تركيزها على عملها السياسي والدبلوماسي
لخدمه بلدها لدرجه ان البعض وصفها بعارضه
ازياء فيما راى اخرون ان منصبها يتطلب
الاهتمام بالمظهر باعتبار انها تمثل واجهه
دوله في الخارج
الى امريكا هذه المره حيث اعلنت سلطات
الامن السيبراني ودول غربيه اخرى وايضا
شركه مايكروسوفت ان جهه فاعله سيبرانيه
مدعومه من بكين تدعى فولت ايفون قد تسللت
الى شبكات البنيه التحتيه الحيويه في
الولايات المتحده بيان لمايكروسوفت اوضح
ان فولت ايفون تنشط منذ منتصف عام 2021
مشيره الى انها استهدفت عددا من البنى
التحتيه الحيويه من بينها البنيه الحيويه
في جزيره غوام الامريكيه حيث تمتلك
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هناك قاعده
عسكريه رئيسيه في المحيط الهادئ
ما زالت قصه اختفاء لاعب المصارعه المصري
احمد فؤاد بخدوده تثير تفاعلا واسعا في
مصر وفي اخر تطوراتها تدخل الرئيس عبد
الفتاح السيسي لحل الازمه اذ وجهت
الاكاديميه الوطنيه للتدريب بناء على
توجيهات السيسي دعوه للاعب لتلقي منحه
للتدريب والتاهيل مع رعايه تامه له كموهبه
رياضيه مصريه وعيده فيما كان بغدوده
البالغ من العمر 22 عاما قد هرب من بعثه
منتخب بلده في تونس بعدما خصمت الضرائب
مبلغ 14 الف جنيه من مستحقاته الماليه
البالغه 18,000
لا مكان للمستحيل مع العلم هذا ما حصل مع
شاب هولندي بعد اكثر من 12 عاما على
فقدانه الامل بالمشي نتيجه تعرضه لحادث
السير صحيفه الجاردن البريطانيه اوضحت ان
الشاب تمكن من الوقوف والمشي بعد ما قيل
له انه لن يحرك قدميه مره اخرى كل حياته
مشيره الى ان الاطباء زرعوا له جهازا يقرا
موجات دماغه ويرسل تعليمات الى عموده
الفقري لتحريك العضلات لتنجح العمليه
ويبدا الشاب الان بصعود السلالم والمشي
لنحو 100 متر في كل محاوله منذ زرع له هذا
الجهاز
[موسيقى]